au canada et ça c'est pas un regret pour
un choc be nice
la photo date de 2001 il avait 29 ans et
on y voit justin trudeau alors âgé de 29
ans dans un dans une soirée déguisée
vêtu d'une tunique portant un turban le
visage le cou il est au milieu à et les
mains noircies il s'agissait d'une
soirée costumée le thème c'était les
mille et une nuits et celui qui allait
devenir le premier ministre du canada
figure internationale du
multiculturalisme se déguise selon ses
termes le site en costume d'allada y
compris avec le maquillage c'est donc ce
qu'on appelle du blackface pratique qui
consiste pour une personne blanche à se
maquiller en noir est perçu aujourd'hui
comme raciste la photo a été retrouvé et
diffusée par le magazine américain time
explications du premier ministre
canadien
m
a été au lycée parce qu'il était prof je
précise des risques il a raison ce de
s'excuser justin trudeau
non mais il est pris à son propre piège
alors évidemment il se montre il fait
des exercices de contrition il ay les
deux ce qui favorise justement ce genre
de procès de mise en accusation et bien
ça se retourne contre lui
maintenant ce qui est préoccupant c'est
effectivement de voir toute cette
thématique a siégé finalement la moins
de campagne électorale la moindre
personnalité se voit donc c'est surtout
l'invasion de toutes ces catégories qui
est très préoccupante
mathieu ce qui est assez sincère pour
vous c'est l'embarras de la photo quand
justin trudeau jeu il est sans doute
très embarrassé et il est peut-être
sincère je n'ai pas de vous avoue que je
suis pas très à l'aise avec le sujet
parce que en voyant la photo je ne suis
pas plus scandalisé que sa star quand je
la trouve tout à fait maladroite
évidemment mais encore une fois enfin je
moi pour mes 40 ans je me suis déguisé
en elfe et je sais que je serais nommé à
matignon ce qui ne manquera pas
d'arriver au sortir à cette photo et je
serai au minois on va justifier
d'ailleurs je suis venu d'ailleurs je
suis venu avec non il est évident que
bon si on doit payer pour toutes les
bêtises qu'on a fait quand on avait 15
ans 20 ans ou même 40 quand on est quand
on est un peu attardé non c'est
évidemment il serait il se serait
déguisé ainsi aujourd'hui en étant
premier ministre tout le monde
considérait que c'est c'est une c'est
une énorme c'est au delà de la
maladresse et de la faute politique
bon il a dit qu'il s'était déguisé en
aladin je sais pas s'ils se déguisait en
aladin est tu n'es qu'une faute
politique majeure sadis a dit à mon avis
quand même juste deux choses si on fait
un pas de côté parce que je pense que
cette affaire va quand même s'éteindre
assez vite il faut souhaiter que cette
affaire c'est allé assez vite dès lors
qu'en plus il fait acte de contrition
voilà avec un minimum de sincérité je
pense mais bon c'est pas c'est pas
énorme estime comme histoire il est vrai
qu'il ya un côté arroseur arrosé c'est
un peu méchant de le dire comme ça mais
évidemment il sait il s'est positionné
comme le héros comme le comme le héros
du multiculturalisme et où aucun
évidemment c'est le mois des liens
ambiance cette annonce a dit quelque
chose parce que je suis historien de
formation et donc depuis toujours
attachés à la question des sources des
traces des archives etc
comment une société conserve ceux
capables de construire sa propre mémoire
à partir des traces et des sources
qu'elle conserve la ce a dit quelque
chose de notre société numérique
il n'ya pas d'amnésie numérique dans une
société numérique en fait tous se
gardent tous se conserve et donc tout
ressort on verra combien de temps ça
dure mais aujourd'hui en pâture est
russe il n'y a pas de prescription n'ont
cessé sa fille en tout cas la question
de savoir comment une société numérique
est capable de construire sa propre
mémoire aura servi d'instrument du
canada donc on lui demandait son avis
oui j'en du québec toute assez alors les
bains une différence entre le québec et
le canada
j'espère bien il ya deux sortes de
réactions justement qu'on observe outre
atlantique
les québécois qui se demandent
majoritairement francophone qui se
demandent pourquoi un déguisement on
peut devenir une affaire d'état
et puis du côté du canada anglophone bon
ben ça serait la manifestation
dans racisme alors peut-être qu'il
n'était pas conscient mais c'est ça en
fait c'est tout simplement cessé suis un
petit peu d'une américanisation de nos
esprits et le canada en est victime
parce que c'est une leçon d'histoire qui
est propre aux états unis au sud des
états unis
mais en aucun cas ce qu'on appelle
blackface avait une connotation une
connotation raciste que ce soit au
canada ou en france en europe plus
largement
oui ça parce qu'il faut que vous
préciser ce qu'on va compresser sec le
blackface c'était aussi une pratique de
certains blancs du sud des états unis
qui consistait à se grimer en noir pour
ceux pour monter sur scène et que c'est
raciste notamment assisté fait que ça le
canada s'était à l'époque de la
ségrégation le cas de nadal n'a pas
connu la france mon coin
et donc voilà une espèce
d'américanisation c'est un belge sur
scène avec et puis on se moquait aussi
des asiatiques
donc c'est pareil cas il était beau si
c'est une auto discrimination ça nous
renvoie aussi en tout cas on veut nous
renvoyer à la couleur de peau on veut
nous renvoyer à la race quelque chose
que l'on pensait avoir dépasser
l'idéologie multiculturelle
multiculturaliste ne l'a pas dépasser et
aujourd'hui c'est l'antichambre de quoi
après de la prod ce qu'on appelle
l'appropriation culturelle
est-ce que trudeau a eu raison ou pas de
le faire oui si l'on en croit son
idéologie
c'est à dire que pour lui c'est le
premier moralisateur celle là c'est
l'arroseur arrosé là c'était le premier
justement à distribuer les bons et les
mauvais points
c'est lui quand même qui a dit au sujet
de la laïcité chose à laquelle est
intimement attachés sont intimement
attacher les québécois que c'était digne
de la ségrégation des états unis dans
les années 50
donc qu'ils fassent comme ça cette mise
en scène de la pénitence c'est pas
surprenant du tout c'est pas surprenant
et puis son camp lui pardonnera marc
landré un avis sur la question monsieur
je me demandais que ce qui ferait quand
on découvrira qu'il a trompé sa copine à
15 ans parce que là ils étaient même
très fort
de contrition franchement s'il pouvait
pleurer ça serait encore mieux mais
enfin je trouve ça ridicule et le procès
qu'on lui fait et son acte de contrition
de repentance choisir c'est stupide
l'association enfin sa vision lui c'est
une passion aidant on en parle et sa
femme alice et son toit laquelle il nous
faut lutter et je ferai un parallèle les
quelques temps jean marie bigard a fait
une blague complètement nulle sur je
crois que c'était chez hanouna sur le
viol il a été il a été vilipendé pour ça
il ya des prix là des salles de
spectacles qui sont décommandés sous
suez csa a reçu des tonnes de plainte et
je me suis replongé parce que je m'en
reste ça m'a rappelé une une ça m'a
rappelé un sketch de dupontel
il a fait la plaidoirie qui datait de la
fin des années 80 où il jouait le rôle
sur scène d'un avocat qui défend des un
violeur ce qu'il faisait il ya 30 ans ne
pourrait pu le faire aujourd'hui parce
qu'on se rend compte que les moeurs
évoluent et surtout notre capacité à
accepter ce qu'on considérait comme
étant drôle il ya 30 ans a complètement
changé et aujourd'hui aussi et je bloque
fixe n'existait pas il ya cinq ans moi
lorsque je voudrais dire c'est justement
le blackface nous nous avons surtout
découvert cela donc au moment de la
représentation des supply et des
suppliante défilent et ce qui a quand
même été absolument terrible c'est que
le metteur en scène quand il a donc
justement de jouer la polémique donc à
8,2 supplions voilà le cran et d'autres
associations ont obtenu l'annulation de
ce spectacle quand on a un niveau au
regard des menaces et une autre sphère
sur v et sur les suppliantes de weeds
qui est intéressant dans la sphère des
supplions tu donc de cette mise en scène
donc le metteur en scène lui aussi a
fait acte de presque 2 construit sion en
disant bon bah je ne mesurais pas assez
et quand il a remonté la pièce eh bien
il a finalement abdiqué signé la
reddition et il a renoncé à ces masques
et pour justement faire allégeance en
définitive à cette idéologie
donc il n'ya justement que causeur qui
véritablement a pointé cette conversion
fille
allemand du metteur en scène parce que
est d'abord sa première phrase c'était
de dire c'est absolument terrible parce
que finalement nous sommes tous
africains et donc et ensuite il revient
enfin il remonte la pièce ils apprirent
présente et là il abdique
donc on voit aussi quand même les
pressions qui sont exercées par ces
associations et l'intimidation que ce
terme arrive à une intimidation que
produit quand même donc toutes ces
accusations alors un certain nombre de
réactions nos internautes heureusement
corson wells est mort nous des citoyens
payeurs
on lui ont reproché son maquillage dans
othello ça devient ridicule tout ça
brownie tout tout dépend de la démarche
derrière le blackface y voir la volonté
de ridiculiser les noirs c'est
généralement plus que déplacés oui non
ça c'est carrément raciste on est
d'accord que c'est babineau la blackface
a une signification particulière en
amérique du nord
c'est embarrassant pour lui brownie tôt
encore là blackface est aussi associé il
me semble le fait que dans les films
hollywoodiens on utilisait des acteurs
blancs pour jouer des noirs je ne suis
pas au courant de précision mais merci
de lui apporter la dictature du
politiquement correct ne nous mène pas
une société moins raciste est plutôt en
bien au contraire
c'est ce qu'estime également bruno tour
posé la question sur dictature du
politiquement correct droit ça
mériterait quand même un tout petit peu
de nuances si c'est si ces sujets là
mais on a mais soyons quand même un tout
petit peu sérieux c'est à dire que notre
société est moins menacée par la censure
ou la dictature de la bien-pensance que
quand même par ailleurs ce qui découle
de ce que fut le racisme pendant
longtemps et qui est aujourd'hui en fait
juste source d'inspiration n'interdisait
je vais quand même terminé ma phrase par
leur nom et s'extrait bien la france est
plus menacé par le politiquement correct
que par le racisme et je pense que vous
n'êtes pas vous même dans votre vie
victimes de discrimination un vide
ignoré par en fait quand même compris
aux france élite
y compris en fondation pour genève
l'accepté dit ce que je veux dire
donc vous connaissez des saignements
tout vous êtes sensé on vous êtes
victime en tout état de cause il
ignorait pas qu'il y a dans la société
française des discriminations et que si
des gens réagissent de façon je vais
essayer de terminer mon propos
si les gens réagissent si des gens
réagissent de façon peut-être même
disproportionnée à ce type de réalité
c'est parce que cette réalité la revois
à ce qu'est la réalité des
discriminations construction idéologique
forte ya cinq ans personne ne savait en
europe et même que là mêmes que celles
qui ont secoué en janvier le ppi dernier
terminée si vous je vous répondais pas
son prochain celui au canada ni en
europe on ne savait pas vous demander à
quelqu'un ce que veut dire blackface
personne ne le savait vous pouviez voler
opposé dans les termes même la dictature
de la bien-pensance dictature de la
bien-pensance a quand même la réalité
d'une société qui continue à être y
compris en france y compris chez nous où
le terme d'égalité est inscrit au
frontispice de toutes les écoles nous
sommes dans une société alors là vous
vous accompagne dans une société cirmad
hammam et non mais à ce moment là c'est
le même discours que mélenchon je vais
dire où on est dans un pays où la
justice n'existe pas là
la menace est discret mais l'addition
justement jamais travaillé ou les
discriminations existent et existe deux
façons de ference pas uniquement pour
d'autres elle n'existe mais nous allons
payer la peau noire ou un nom à
consonance avant déposé un dossier pour
avoir un appartement non mais écoutez
ali
lisez philippe d'iribarne il avait il a
justement fait le point sur cette
question qui est absolument manipuler
non continuera d'avoir ce débat je pense
que le débat sur l'histoire du
politiquement correct et de
discrimination est un débat qui est
extrêmement passionnant et passionné
nationale aussi et qui mérite d'être
posée et qu'on continuera d'avoir on a
des potable on a des protagonistes pour
pouvoir en discuter
je rappelle la question composé sur
twitter êtes vous convaincu pas les
excuses de justin trudeau après la
publication d'une photo datant de 2001
sur laquelle il fait une blague faith
est pour l'instant vous êtes une
majorité à être convaincu par la
sincérité de la démarche du premier
ministre canadien